a veces a estas series queremos de
llevarlas pero también a veces queremos
integrarlas en general podemos hacer
cualquiera de las dos cosas término por
término ya qué me refiero con esto bueno
pues lo que quiero decir es que en
general la derivada de f f prima de x es
la suma de la derivada de cada uno de
estos términos
la suma desde que n es igual a 1 hasta
infinito de la derivada de este término
ahora si lo derivamos nos queda n por x
elevado a la n 1 n por x a la n menos 1
y todo eso entre en estas dos n se
cancelan por lo que nos queda x elevada
a la potencia en el -1 aquí lo que
hicimos fue tomar la derivada con
respecto de x
de la misma forma podemos encontrar la
integral de efe de x con respecto a x
que es igual a una constante más la suma
de las integrales de cada uno de estos
términos la suma desde que en es igual a
1 hasta infinito de y para integrar este
término tomamos el exponente le sumamos
1 y dividimos entre el exponente
completo o sea que nos queda x a la n 1
entre n 1 por n
n esta es una técnica muy común que te
vas a encontrar muchas veces cuando
estés lidiando con series de potencias
pero vamos a ir un poco más a fondo
porque es muy importante saber que solo
se puede hacer esto para las equis que
están dentro del intervalo de
convergencia y como vamos a ver los
intervalos de convergencia de cada una
de estas series son muy parecidos pero
lo que sucede en los puntos finales del
intervalo es distinto
así es que propongo que le pongas una
pausa a este vídeo e intentes encontrar
los intervalos de convergencia de cada
una de estas series esta es la integral
de nuestra serie original y esta es la
derivada de la serie original vamos a
encontrar el intervalo de convergencia y
podemos hacerlo utilizando el criterio
de la razón el criterio de la razón nos
dice que tenemos que encontrar el límite
cuando n tiende a infinito
n 1 / n pero a n 1 en este caso es x a
la n 1 entre n 1 y queremos dividir a n
1 entre a n pero a n es x a la n / n y
no se nos olvide el valor absoluto esto
es igual al límite cuando n tiende a
infinito y para simplificar esto vamos a
dividir numerador y denominador entre x
a la n x a la n entre x a la n es un 1
pero x a la n 1 / x a la n es
simplemente x la n termina arriba y n 1
termina abajo y listo que es igual al
límite cuando n tiende a infinito de
ahora vamos a dividir numerador y
denominador entre n
y nos queda en el numerador simplemente
equis y en el denominador entre n es uno
más uno entre en el valor absoluto y
esto a cuánto es igual
bueno pues uno entre n se va a ir a cero
cuando n se vaya a infinito y nos queda
simplemente el valor absoluto de x pero
a ver qué es lo que nos dice el criterio
de la razón si este límite que ya vimos
que es igual al valor absoluto de x es
estrictamente menor que 1 el criterio de
la razón nos dice que esta serie
converge si es mayor que 1 la serie
diverge pero si es exactamente igual a 1
el criterio de la razón es inconcluso no
nos puede decir nada vamos a escribirlo
caso por caso
esta serie converge para los valores de
x que son estrictamente menores que 1
esta serie
converge si este límite que es el valor
absoluto
es menor que 1 y diverge para x
estrictamente mayor que 1 pero qué pasa
cuando el valor absoluto de x es
exactamente igual a 1 en estos casos el
criterio de la razón no dice nada y
tenemos que evaluarlo caso por caso así
es que vamos a analizar el escenario en
el que x es igual a 1 en este caso la
serie es la suma desde que n es igual a
1 hasta infinito de 1 entre n 1 entre n
y esta serie ya la conocemos la hemos
visto en otros vídeos esta es la serie
armónica o también podemos decir que es
una de las series pp y de hecho hemos
visto en varios vídeos que esta serie en
particular divergen
divergen así es que cuando x es igual a
1 la serie divergen
pero qué pasa cuando x es igual a menos
1 en este caso la serie se convierte en
la suma desde que en es igual a 1 hasta
infinito de menos 1 elevado a la n entre
n y esta es conocida como la serie
armónica alternante y aquí el criterio
de las series alternantes nos dicen que
ésta converge converge y eso también ya
lo hemos visto en otros vídeos así es
que el intervalo de convergencia de esta
serie
el intervalo de convergencia son todas
las x mayores o iguales a menos uno
porque x todavía puede ser igual a menos
uno porque esta serie converge pero x
tiene que ser estrictamente menor que 1
porque justo cuando x es igual a 1 la
serie diverge así es que x tiene que ser
estrictamente menor que 1 y listo ya
tenemos aquí el intervalo de
convergencia para la serie original pero
ahora pensemos qué pasa con el intervalo
de convergencia de la serie que
obtuvimos derivando a ver veamos esta
serie derivada esta es igual a x a la 0
más x a la 1 más x al cuadrado más todos
los términos que siguen después porque
así se sigue y tal vez tú ya reconociste
cuál es esta serie
esta es una serie geométrica con radio
común x esta es una serie geométrica con
razón común x es una serie geométrica
pero con razón x ahora nosotros sabemos
que las series geométricas convergen
con bergé si y sólo si el valor absoluto
de la razón común es estrictamente menor
que 1 por lo que en este caso cuando
tomamos la derivada cuando tomamos f
prima de x nuestro intervalo de
convergencia es casi el mismo en esta
serie el intervalo de convergencia son
las x que son mayores que menos 1 y
menores que 1 en este intervalo de
convergencia x no puede ser exactamente
igual a menos 1 porque en ese caso la
serie divergen si x es igual a menos 1
la serie divergen
y también si x es igual a 1 la serie
también divergen así es que estos dos
radios de convergencia se parecen
muchísimo pero no son iguales
ambos son intervalos de convergencia
centrados en cero y tienen el mismo
radio ambos pueden irse uno hacia abajo
y uno hacia arriba y esta similitud
generalmente sucede siempre que
derivamos o integramos una serie
pero tenemos que tener mucho cuidado en
los puntos finales de los intervalos
porque pueden ser distintos bueno y
ahora te propongo que tú encuentres cuál
es el intervalo de convergencia de la
anti derivada de la integral de esta
serie puedes utilizar el criterio de la
razón pero no se te olvide analizar los
casos límite lo que vas a encontrar es
un intervalo centrado en cero que puede
ir uno hacia abajo y uno hacia arriba
pero no es exactamente el mismo
intervalo porque como vas a ver esta
serie converge si x es igual a menos 1 y
también converge si x es exactamente
igual a 1 bueno vamos a escribirlo de
una vez
esta serie converge si x es mayor o
igual a menos 1 y menor o igual a 1 y
observa todas estas series tienen el
mismo radio de convergencia pero el
intervalo de convergencia cambia en los
finales y si tú quieres demostrar que
este es el intervalo de convergencia de
esta serie te recomiendo que utilices un
método similar al que utilizamos con la
serie original empieza con el criterio
de la razón vas a llegar a esta misma
conclusión pero luego todavía falta
analizar los casos cuando x es igual a 1
y cuando x es igual a menos uno cuando x
es igual a menos uno vas a obtener una
serie alternante que si convergen y
luego cuando x es igual a 1 vas a
obtener una p serie pero cuyo
denominador tiene un grado mayor que 1
por lo tanto esa p serie también
converge o bueno te va a quedar algo muy
parecido a una p serie con un grado
mayor que uno y va a ser muy fácil
analizar este escenario y determinar que
esa serie si converge